i said i wasn't going to post another video
about sunscreen but hi it's michelle from lab
muffin beauty science chemistry phd and skincare
nerd and serial sunscreen video maker in case you
haven't already heard the 2021 version of this
anti-cancer product is actually giving you cancer
is that there's been benzene found in a bunch
of sunscreens how much should we be freaking out
about this i did an instagram post on this already
but i thought i'd elaborate a bit more in a video
like subscribe nerdification bell you know
the drill first let's talk about the results
before we go into some of the more questionable
things about this report it's from valisure a
us-based online pharmacy that brands themselves
as the pharmacy that checks the premise is the
fda doesn't regulate drugs as closely as valley
shore would like so valley shore test them before
they sell them so valley shore bought a bunch of
products and sent them to some labs for testing
using gas chromatography it was sunscreen and
after sun care products from 294 batches from
69 different brands they found benzene at low pass
per million concentrations in 78 of these most of
them were spray sunscreens there was over 2 parts
per million in 14 different batches between 0.1
and 2 parts per million and 26 and the rest were
below 0.1 parts per million for reference two
parts per million is one one fiftieth of a drop
in a product this big and one three hundredth of
a drop in a product this big they pick two parts
per million because that's the limit that the fda
recommends for products like hand sanitizers
and medications the table in attachment a
also has a list of sunscreens where they didn't
detect any benzene i've seen a lot of stuff online
about this that just isn't quite right so let's
clear up a few things firstly no one is purposely
adding benzene to products benzene doesn't really
have a purpose in cosmetics it's not a fragrance
it doesn't absorb uv strongly enough to be used
as a sunscreen it's not a preservative it has
no beneficial function that can't be done more
safely and cheaply with a different ingredient
benzene is a trace contaminant so it's in there
because it was an impurity in another ingredient
or something happened during the manufacturing
process it's also not an issue that's specific
to sunscreens there was benzene found in after
sun care products in that highest group and
this was an issue that was in hand sanitizers in
an earlier report it's not because of particular
sunscreen ingredients or chemical sunscreens
both mineral and chemical sunscreens show up
on the list valley shul also checked raw sunscreen
ingredients for benzene and they didn't find any
there are some sunscreen ingredients that sort
of look like the word benzene but they don't
have anything to do with benzene sort of like how
lady gaga doesn't have much to do with galileo
it also isn't a problem with particular brands
all of the brands tested that had high benzene
also had products with no benzene except for
the one brand that only had one product tested
it's also not specific to particular products
all of the products where they tested more than
one batch had different levels of benzene so
it seems like sometimes when the brand made the
product there was more benzene and then sometimes
when they made it there was less so if you want
to find out if your product has benzene in it you
don't just match the name of the product you also
want to match the other parts of the table the
upc lot and expiry date there are also 4 lists
so make sure you're looking at the right list if
it says nd that means they didn't detect benzene
but how worried should we actually be about
benzene there are two phrases in the report
that i think were misinterpreted and they make
benzene sound a lot scarier than it actually is
benzene is a known human carcinogen
and there's no safe level of benzene
and it kind of sounds like anyone who's used one
of these sunscreens has upped their chances of
cancer by a lot but that's not really true known
human carcinogen is a classification from the iarc
these classifications known probable and possible
human carcinogen tell us about how certain the
evidence is that something increases the chance
of cancer it doesn't tell us how big that increase
actually is so some things that are really potent
are in the same category as things that are a lot
weaker for example we know that walking near a
dog definitely increases your risk of getting
bitten by a dog so does punching a dog so they're
both known dog bite causes but obviously one of
these is much worse we can see this in action by
looking at some of the other known carcinogens so
smoking cigarettes and eating processed meat i
think we all know there's a massive difference
in the risk from smoking cigarettes versus eating
a few slices of salami and on top of that i think
we all know there's a big difference between
smoking one cigarette when you were 16 and
smoking 30 cigarettes a day for 50 years you might
remember from my video about clean beauty the idea
of hazards versus risks these classifications are
hazard-based if you haven't watched that check it
out it really puts the idea of toxic chemicals in
your beauty products into perspective the other
phrase that i think got taken out of context is
that there's probably no safe level of benzene
combined with known human carcinogen i think it
really makes it sound like any exposure to benzene
is dangerous but if you look at the rest of
the sentence in this toxicology context safe
means absolutely zero effect no safe level means
that little exposures can add up but the question
is how much is the benzene in sunscreen adding
to the amount of benzene we're already getting
a few of us pointed out on instagram that we're
actually exposed to quite a lot of benzene in our
everyday lives so we need to think about that to
contextualize how much extra we're getting from
the benzene in sunscreens we mostly get benzene by
inhaling it so for example in petrol or gasoline
if you're american there's one to three percent
benzene so we can compare it more easily that's
ten to thirty thousand parts per million cigarette
smoke and bushfires also have benzene also indoor
air there's tiny bits of benzene that's left
over in manufacturing plastics and stuff that
get released into the air over time we also eat
it in food and it's in drinking water but these
amounts that we get in everyday life aren't enough
to lead to cancer the link to cancer is with much
higher amounts so usually with industrial exposure
where workers are working with benzene every day
for most of us we inhale 3 to 40 micrograms
per cubic meter of air and this is about a
thousand times lower than the amount that's been
found to be problematic and linked to cancer
now for skin contact like we'd get with sunscreens
unfortunately there's a lot less information
that's because the main concern with benzene is
industrial exposure and most industrial exposure
is from inhaling it benzene is volatile which
means most of it actually evaporates before it has
a chance to get through your skin into your body
how much gets through your skin really depends
on what the benzene is in but in general it's a
fraction of a percent of the amount that you apply
and not all of the stuff that gets through the
skin actually makes it to the rest of your body
one paper estimated that a worker who puts their
hands and lower half of their forearms in one
thousand parts per million benzene for one hour
a day and their skin is damaged so it's going
to absorb more than normal then over 40 years
they'd have a relative risk of leukemia of 1.42
so that means they're one and a half times more
likely to develop leukemia compared to someone
who didn't have this exposure to benzene but if
this was a hundred parts per million instead then
there would be close to no increased risk
of leukemia so 100 parts per million was
the limit recommended for workers in sunscreens
the highest amount was six parts per million so
based on the evidence it doesn't really seem like
six parts per million is going to make that much
of a difference joe schwartz chemistry professor
and professional debunker thinks that there's an
infinitesimal chance that the benzene in sunscreen
will lead to any significant amount in blood
don't get me wrong benzene is definitely harmful
there's no benefit to it i'm not recommending
that you slather yourself on purpose with lots
of benzene we should be reducing our exposure
to things like benzene and it's a good thing that
regulators are working on it but like with other
harmful and hazardous things our risk depends on
our exposure the harm depends on how much you get
and how you're exposed to it and this aspect gets
lost a lot of the time when we're talking about
scary things on our beauty products i've talked
about this in the context of dirty lists from
clean beauty companies but this sort of scary
story has been happening for a long time before
clean beauty for example there was a big thing
about lead and lipstick in like the late 90s
early 2000s there are trace amounts of lead and
lipstick and there's nothing beneficial about lead
but the amounts and lipstick are so tiny that
they're not going to have any real effect on
your health there are a few things in the valley
shore report that i think are a bit confusing so
for example the dermatologist that they quoted
as an expert says there is not a safe level of
benzene that can exist in sunscreen products and
even benzene at 0.1 parts per million in sunscreen
could expose people to excessively high nanogram
amounts of benzene i think this doesn't really
reflect what we know about the toxicology of
benzene for example in the eu benzene is allowed
in some cosmetic ingredients as an impurity if
it's below 1000 parts per million to make it below
0.1 plus per million these ingredients would have
to be used at less than 100 of a percent and these
ingredients are used at much higher concentrations
than that the excessively high nanogram amounts of
benzene bit is also really weird because we're
normally exposed to much higher amounts that we
measure in micrograms not nanograms a 2010 paper
estimated that non-smokers inhale about 200 to
450 micrograms or 200 000 to 450 000 nanograms of
benzene a day and again this amount is really tiny
compared to the industrial exposures that were
actually linked to cancer there's also a really
scientifically er comparison in the report there's
another not very nice substance called ndma not
mdma that's been found in some pills and the fda
has limited that to two parts per million as well
this translates to 96 nanograms a day so they
use this as a comparable benchmark to the amount
of benzene you get from sunscreen if you apply
four shot glasses with two parts per million this
comparison is really whack for a number of reasons
so obviously we apply a lot more sunscreen than a
tablet-sized amount so if they were allowed at the
same concentration then benzene is obviously a lot
safer like if you compare one caffeine tablet to
four shot glasses of caffeine tablets the thing
you can throw back four shots of is obviously
going to be a lot safer and of course it's also a
completely different route of exposure we swallow
tablets we don't swallow sunscreen well i'm not
going to assume i know what you do with your
life but it's a silly comparison there's also the
disposal recommendations so valley sure recommend
that you dispose of the benzene sunscreens
as hazardous waste but as this environmental
scientist who works with hazardous waste points
out it is a really tiny amount of benzene 1 300th
of a drop in a tube this size hazardous waste
people are probably not going to know what to say
if you ask them about it the fact that sunscreen
sprays are flammable is probably a bigger safety
issue again i think benzene is harmful and i'm not
saying that you shouldn't reduce your exposure to
it but hopefully this gives you some context for
how worried you should be if you've been using
one of these sunscreens or if you're using a
sunscreen that hasn't been tested also it's good
to remember that benzene in personal care products
has never been linked to cancer but uv exposure
has i would personally probably stop using
products from the batches that were measured to
have higher amounts i would probably still hold on
to them though in case we get more information or
if there's a recall will the fda actually issue a
recall well i think joe schwartz is right it's not
really scientifically justified but the government
does a lot of things that aren't scientifically
justified save sunscreens check out my video on
clean beauty if you haven't already i also
have tons of other videos about sunscreens
thanks to stephen for helping me with this video
also wasabi.gif for her insights check them both
out on instagram if you haven't already
next video is definitely not sunscreen